When it comes to email, good etiquette is not about the fancy flourishes,...
...it's about respecting other people's time.
When I was researching my recent book on digital etiquette,...
...one of the people I spoke to was American writer and podcaster Merlin Mann.
He's the person who coined the term Inbox Zero.
If you haven't heard of that,...
...it's basically a method for staying on top of your unread emails.
I won't get into it here, but if you have an overfull inbox,...
...it will change your life.
Anyway, when I asked him what he thought constituted good email etiquette,...
...he said, "Assume that everyone you're communicating with...
...is smarter than you and cares more than you and is busier than you."
I think that's excellent advice.
So, no waffling.
No jargon.
No small talk.
You do not have to ask after your recipient's health every time you email them.
That said, it is possible to be too concise.
There's a line where brevity crosses over into rudeness.